different culture and you know I know all white nationalists
in in America think that if you're white that you have exact
same culture but no American Americans are so different in culture
that from from us for example I have more in common with my Zerbani
friend okay and he's a Muslim and you know yeah so it's just
I have right that yeah you know I'm just not to be dramatic but
uh right now people in my country before they get shot in the
head are forced to listen sing Soviet anthem I just want to point
that communist idea >> [__] ever. >> That's
an idea. Yeah, that's how they justified the red terror. Uh they
uh had the uh in my city, by the way. They were >> the
proletarian masses. >> Yes. Yes. They thought they were
doing the great thing in my city. They had like skinned people
alive. They shot them. They put them on meat hooks during red
terror period. 3,000 people just keeps happening. Just keeps
happening, man. I don't know. Okay, one of two things here.
I'm gonna do the Ukrainian Anna stuff. It has to be done. Unfortunately,
it has to be done. >> She's going off. >> She's going
unhinged.
She's going crazy on people. Okay, we have to do the Ukrainian
stuff. Unfortunately,
I don't want to. I don't really want to, but it has to be done.
I'll give you guys a quick preview and then I'm going to do the
ESOS Shaggy thread on Tucker Carlson real quick and then we'll
come back and do the Ukrainian stuff. Okay.
But Anna's it's too much. Okay. It's too much. It's too much.
>> The only thing for the CI CIA I found for Peter Teal
is this company got funding from it maybe. >> Um Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. So Peter Teal. Yes. But the Yeah. Teal, that's what
I that's what I just said was basically like, oh, they get contracts
from the CIA probably, but it's like a a data harvesting company.
It always has been. So it's natural that they would. All right.
So
short fat otaku tweets this out. This is just funny for Econo
Boy to come on stream with like the flags behind him, right?
This is just funny. Yes, it's up that like these countries kill
people or what people whatever,
but it's just a funny bit, right? It's a funny bit. Anna quote
tweets this and says, "Would a right-winger meme with a swastika
after being accused uh for sweeping or being useful idiots for
fascists? And how funny would we find it?" Probably not very.
Uh the thing that makes it funny is that it's preposterous to
compare Econo Boy to like the authoritarian communists that the
flags represent, right? That he has none of those ideals. He
doesn't believe in that at all. But he was being accused of that
and he is mocking the who are accusing him of it. Right. >> Is
it funny from someone actively being bombard bombed though? There's
no Russian flag here. There's a Soviet Union flag. There's no
Russian flag. Econ boy absolutely supports Ukraine. Right. This
is just absurd. This is absurd when you when you do this and
then you also are like coming on Destiny's stream to be like
this pixie girl's a gold digger. She's like a gold digging [__]
>> Oh yeah, she did do that. >> Like there's no way
you can come back and go, "Oh, but also this guy joking with
these flags is like over the line. That's [__] nuts,
right?" Oh, Koser, I'm not on that account anymore,
just so you know. Uh send it in the Discord or something if you
can or try to find my my current account. Yeah, I dude there's
no way. There's no way. I thought jokes were legal now that this
is soying out for like the company you keep. This is soying out
insanely, right? This is insane from a purely influencer point
of view. You can't you can't do this. Can't soy out about this.
Decidedly not funny to me. Anyway, sorry. I'm not going to read
the rest of that right now. We'll cover it cuz then she I believe
she did a wick panel tonight. If we get more time, I believe
there's also a wick. Oh god, there's a top post on r/ Destiny.
No way. The top There's no way. The top comment has to be, "Okay,
you're losing it right now." Or, "Okay, yeah, this is too far."
The top post, I'll predict it, okay? Before I see it, I'll predict
it. It's going to be, "Well, um, you know, I I get it cuz she's
being bombed by Russia." So, I get it. I get it. But like, really,
we It's just a funny joke. And I I have infinite empathy for
this person cuz I sent the money, right? That's what it has to
be. That has to be the top comment. If it's anything but that,
they've they've jumped the shark >> Well, the top's going
to be, "How dare you do this? Your country's getting bombed.
How many people are getting killed by the Russians? How dare
you support communism?" I think that's going to be Yeah, >> it's
uh Oh, it's literally
uh
it's not it's not it's not that. It's uh somebody posted the
thing. She saw this live with counter counter points and wick.
She was genuinely upset talking about it and isn't just and isn't
just looking for a fight. Yeah, nobody thinks she's looking for
a fight. It's just it's like totally soy and given the other
things that other positions she has, right? This is totally but
I would say I understand how she might not find not might not
find it funny, but you can't make other jokes and like what did
she call this guy like a for communist or something? I don't
know. It's it's crazy. It's genuinely charming how much she hates
commie scum. Is this a real pick or just some sort of Photoshop?
It's real. It's real. So people aren't like saying this is clearly
soy as [__] Nobody's saying she's It's embarrassing
that this is her real honest post. It's embarrassing.
There's nobody in DG that can possibly sweep for this. That can
possibly go, "Oh, actually, yeah, this is really just too far,
guys. This is too far." Was it too far when she called Pixia
a gold digging? Sorry. Gold digger. Probably gold digger. Was
that too far? I feel like some people would think that's too
>> You could cut her some flag. They're doing red scare
over there in DG. Huh. I don't even know if it's like this is
just like we've already established what economy's beliefs are.
He's like, "Yeah, I like um I like democratic socialism."
He doesn't believe any of this. He is mocking the people who
implied that he believes this. Right.
>> That's all this is. >> An effort post. She posted
more under the tweet. >> She posted more under it. Okay.
I can I'm gonna I might come back to the Tucker stuff. I'm going
to read all of it. I'm gonna read all of it and then I'm gonna
go open up this panel because I am I don't Dude, really?
Hold on. Maybe maybe she maybe she fixes it in one of the replies,
guys. Maybe she fixes it in a reply. Okay, so she finds it not
very funny. Decidedly not funny to me, but what do I know? Only
millions of my people died to people with this flag and are currently
being killed by people who glorify it and force us on our knees
to sing Soviet anthem before they us. But hey, it's all jokes.
North Korea is currently invading my country with Russia. And
they're going to send more our way. Apparently, very good time
for jokes. If I was in the US, I would also laugh. I think other
people's pain and death is funnier from far away. What? He's
not But he's not laughing at you and he totally supports Ukraine.
A Connoy's going to do I need a Connoy to do his Brianna Woo
thing. Okay. When do you remember when Brianna Woo tried to come
in and press him and he actually stood up for himself?
>> I think that happened. He didn't just totally, right?
Yeah. Don't on this. Okay. Hey, you already a little bit. This
is a funny joke. There's no way that somebody could support Destiny
joking about those dead kids in Texas and then also soy the out
about this, right? There's 0% chance. I give her a pass, she's
in a war, then she should be more respectful of other people's
pain and suffering, right? If you want to have that standard
where jokes are only funny if they don't hurt somebody, then
that's fine. But do not sit here in the Destiny community. Shut
the up. Thank you. Welcome to my TED talk. This is where she
brings it up on the panel. if you need that. Yeah, maybe we will.
That's all that's all I'm saying, okay? Is if you're going to
have the line of, "Oh, this joke offends me cuz it's personally
painful for me," then appreciate other people's pain or feel
empathy for other people. That's all you got to do.
Why are you acting like this is rational? It doesn't have to
be rational. I'm mocking them for for basically so the [__]
out on Twitter about this. They're like an influencer. They're
trying to be an influencer. This is a opinion. If they if they
come out tomorrow and they go, "Oh, I was emotional because of
uh because of the stuff that's going on." Obviously, but you
know, realistically, I shouldn't be that, you know, I shouldn't
be that critical of people joking. I totally accept it. I take
back all criticism. I say, "Yeah, you're emotional. It's fine."
I'm saying if this is her position, this is stupid. Pretty easy
to understand. Oh, and people suggested I speak with a boy. And
after we had a conversation on Twitter, and he himself said,
"I am sure if we talked we would agree." No, not happening.
It's just supery
boy better stand on business here. Okay. Stand on [__]
business.
Get on the next stream and literally
No, don't don't don't get on the next stream and throw up a Z
behind you. Okay, don't do it. Don't actually do it. Don't actually
do it. That'd be up. That'd be up. Nobody cares about that flag.
Nobody appreciates that flag. All right, we do have the >> fly
Russia right now.
>> We do have the Ukraine Pepe. She's crashing out, but
she can make sense of it. Although, yeah, but full of hell. She
supports people who make jokes about those kids who just died
in Texas right after they died.
Right. Jokes about them. She She's cool with that guy. Do we
not see how
Do we not see how like you being friends with that guy and supporting
him wholeheartedly is a little weird? >> No. Not that person
like actively giving you money for your cause. >> You're
going to support them no matter what. I guess >> I guess
so. You got to give her a pass. I've been giving her a pass.
I've given her a pass on the continued support of Destiny. But
actually, you know what? But if you're going to support Destiny
for the money, then adopt his positions and and take the same
stance on jokes. Don't go halfway and then get mad when people
joke about your [__] Okay? Don't do it. It's Yeah.
Crazy. >> How many How many times How many times have I
actually given her a pass and said, "You know what? I don't care
that she said this. She's DG is her money. DG is how she makes
money. We understand, right?" I've given her a pass like 10 times.
I feel like nobody said this. Literally, nobody said this. I
don't know. I don't know what you're saying. Oh, wait. Maybe
I did say there's no Russian flag back there. It's not He doesn't
support Russia. Like, objectively, he doesn't support Russia.
He supports Ukraine. You think Destiny made dead kid jokes? Yeah,
he did. He objectively did. Why would you Why would you ask that?
Yes. That's just objective fact. What? What? Huh? That was Wait,
are you saying that? I I can't actually. Hold on. I think that
one guy shot me a time stamp for when this comes up in the debate.
Oh, I'm going to have a hard time if she's like crying and emotional.
I'm going to have a really hard time going in on her during this.
[__] me. >> Great discussion. >> Conor
can go [__] real quick. Hope they both die in a car.
>> Hold on. Let's watch Connor Soy out. >> Yeah,
as well, which is all not leftist. >> I'm getting I'm getting
a bunch of I'm getting a bunch of DMs telling me to bring up
live and learn right now. Like I'm getting like check. Yeah,
bring it >> Dude, I didn't know
>> I was not familiar with the Connell Boys game, okay?
I saw I thought he was going to come out to everybody. He kind
of He kind of threw Pisco under the bus with a couple people.
Okay, I think he threw Pisco under the bus, but I respect the
game here. I respect the the joke. The joke is funny. Okay, it's
very funny. >> Uh, what's Lib and Learn? Oh, it's >> that's
Peace Go's Pisco.
>> Hold on. I'll stream it for you guys. Hold on. >> Mali
is a unique last name. They're like, "Anna's a piece of Conor
can go
>> Wait, when did he say Anna's a piece of [__]
A I don't think a Conno boy will actually like, you know, he
won't say what he needs to be said or he won't say what needs
to be said after this. A Connor boy will like out for sure, but
>> No, I believe in. >> No, no, no. I say as in he
should be like off. You're just so performative. It's embarrassing.
He should say some [__] like that, but he won't.
He won't. He'll say something along the lines of like,
"I understand you're at war. It's fine. Whatever, right? Hope
they both die in a car accident. >> I have more chances
to be drowned though. So, >> he called me evil and so I'll
be talking to him about a car. >> Evils of socialism, I
guess, on Wednesday. I'm sure that'll be a great
>> Not finally. Not finally. >> We haven't even
about I guess socialism with me. And so, I'll be talking to him
on Thursday. I figure that'll get a lot of views. I'm going to
try and do a charity stream >> on my Let's just be clear.
And then on Friday, I've got another stream.
>> Is that DPRK,
North Korea, and
Soviet Union.
>> Is that North Korea? DPRK and uh and Cuba and communism.
Is that the communism? That is the communism flag.
put together
and grab the first thing off the [__] >> Sorry,
I'm going to
literally just walkiet
and grab the first thing off the [__] >> So
people can go themselves. Something just died. I don't know.
I don't know what she said there. >> Sorry. I'm going to
click out of that otherwise that's going to pick. That's >> That's
just him trolling gang. That's That's all that is. >> Okay,
I get it. Okay, I get it. So, so and by the way, uh we are in
the internet game where the more attention like you get the the
better it is for you, right? The more people who are going to
listen to you. However,
let's
you you Conor you. Oh, this guy is there's no way there's no
way he's gonna actually call out a Connor boy for this. This
would be so
embarrassing for him. Okay, this would be Well, would it Hold
on. He did uh at least Hold on, hold on, hold on. Maybe not.
Maybe not. Maybe not. Maybe I'm going a little too hard. He doesn't
disavow Destiny. But he does uh he did say like, "Hey, Destiny,
stop talking about [__] kids. Stop talking about
kids." He did at least say that. Okay, at least he got on a stream
and said, "Hey, Destiny, when you make jokes about like 13-year-old
girls or 12-year-old girls getting you look weird. You're a weirdo.
You're like a really weird." So, at least he did that. Okay.
At least he did that.
that I was being accused of being a
and uh and then I was like, "No, no, no. I'm I'm not a I'm actually
just like a
Yeah. Yeah. >> Yeah. And and then I was like, I'm I'm actually
like a libertarian version of a fascist. I believe in political
corporatism, which by the way, I do. I I believe in political
corporatism. Um however, like I'm not like those other guys.
I'm not an authoritarian. And then like the next week as a joke
I have the KKK flag, the flag. >> You would be funny. >> And
like and like the flag of Franco
Spain like Right. >> Yeah. If he had the if he had the
Franco Spain and like the Italian flag hanging up behind him.
Okay. And he stayed away from like the one cuz nobody's really
accusing him of that. Right. I think that would be a little different.
That could be like, "Oh, look guys, I'm I'm a fascist. Haha."
Nobody would get it. But nobody would get it at all. This one
is nowhere near the same to me. And he's mocking the idea that
like
this is I know how you you just you defend this through through
Zogbot tactics. Okay, there are Zogbot defense tactics. Wait,
wait, wait. Connor, are you insisting or are you are you implying,
Connor, that like there's a genocide that's anywhere near like
the Holocaust? Are you saying that like the are the same as some
of these other groups? I I just don't know if I could possibly
agree with that. Actually, I I feel like the Holocaust is very
unique and very special in terms of genocides. Okay, it stands
on its own. I I think it's really disgusting for you to insist
that okay, like somehow any of these communist like famines that
happen are the same thing. There's nowhere near the intent. There's
nowhere near the mechanization. Are you serious?
He would he would fold. He would fold to the Zogbot talking points
100%. like dude >> he and I when I say fold I mean he would
like accept his programming >> but I would expect people
to be like oh you're hiding your power level or you're a piece
of like that's what people would say for the content >> oh
yeah thank you for the know tes thank you very much >> if
I was uh joking about being a >> do you think that this
Hold on I'm I'm going to defend econ boy just for a minute here
do you think that that that's as bad as that like as
wait feels Wick nose.
>> Yes. Yes. >> I think I think North Korea is as
bad as uh Germany. >> I do I do think that the Soviet Union
was you know pretty much the only Okay, here's the thing. >> Oh,
Wick Wick knows he could crucify him for that. Okay, he knows.
Uh, you think like North Korea is as bad as explicitly targeting
like one ethnicity and trying to bring about the the total death
of that ethnicity as a goal? You think North Korea is the same
as that? Really, this is from my perspective. Now, bear in mind,
I'm like a Western capitalist or whatever, but from my perspective,
the only thing that Stalin did that wasn't technically worse
than him is allegedly
he didn't kill people exclusively because of their ethnicity.
However, we are here with Anna right now and I'm pretty sure
that the holymore was at least partial partially motivated by
ethnic bigotry
>> and so and so like dude if I if I see somebody flying
a flag that like and they're saying like lol you know a hundred
years ago my people your so Connor in your opinion the hoodore
is equivalent to the holocaust. Okay, Connor out here arguing
that the homore is equivalent to the Holocaust. He's about to
get a call from Brianna Woo. She is not going to be happy about
this one. She's going to be very upset. Okay, Connor, what are
you doing? >> People to the tunes of millions of
>> I mean, I mean like connected friends. They still like
what's it called? Professionally connected. >> I don't
know. >> They like separate
>> years ago. My >> That's not what he said. I'm
being a little hyperbolic about what he said. He said it's he
said allegedly or what I would what I believe right is allegedly
Stalin did not target people by their ethnicity but Anna believes
they did she says yes right do you think he's saying I just placated
Anna I'm going to pretend that the Holocaust and the hoodom are
kind of close
my people by the way I would agree that probably the hoodore
is like up there and is are really really underrated or underappreciated
or that not those words
uh what would it be underrepresented it's not properly like represented
in modern thought, right? What am I saying? It's underappreciated.
People don't appreciate what Stall was trying to do. Yeah. I'm
saying uh yeah, it's underrepresented or people just don't think
of it correctly. I would say >> your people to the tunes
of millions of people. I'd be
I'd be >> Yeah. You know what? It's just it's something
I
will take on that one. Fair enough. No, >> No, you you
don't have to. Different people view it differently. But I'm
saying like I sympathize with Anna like because like for me it's
a joke. I'm a westerner. We communists for fun in Korea in Vietnam
in the cold war
for parents and grandparents grew. >> You just we just
those people for fun just little little goof just a goof guy
>> grew up under a Soviet regime and they
>> Yeah. You know it's just I I hate this with passion
because this is the sanitization.
So this what he did there is even if it's a meme that's allowed.
So that that's like it's not a problem to walk around with this
flag in the in the in America which is incredibly weird if you
think about it cuz considering how anti-communist America
cold war >> it's just America just allows it
>> even if it's a meme that's allowed. So that that's like
it's not a problem to walk around with this flag >> in
in America, which is incredibly weird if you think about it because
consider how anti-communist America used to be during like Cold
War and all of that, >> Yeah. No, actually because America
is anti-communist, you stupid [__] Okay, that's why
you can do it.
>> You should be call.
You stupid person.
>> Uh-oh. She's kind of correct. What? No, you can walk
around that flag because you have freedom. Don't let anybody
tell you otherwise. You can walk around with that flag because
you have freedom. The freedom to do it, >> right? But currently,
it's completely fine. If he's walking around with a swast sticker,
that will cause some people on the street being likely not happy
to see that. I'm not saying that.
>> Lots of people march around with swastikas. Lots of
people put swastikas
>> Totally legal. Totally allowed. Maybe she's not talking
about legality, she's talking about jobs, people would disassociate
from him if he put her.
>> that's that's probably true, but that's because you
know the Hey, if she wants to start railing about the Holocaust
industry or something, okay, she can go off, but it's just got
a different place in the American zeitgeist. Okay. >> Yes.
No, and that's the problem. I do think I do think you Connor
and Destiny are right that we do need to
it it's weird that socialism and communism specifically don't
get more
uh more of a stigma which means that if a con boy chose to use
fost yes but he doesn't believe in he doesn't believe in fascism
he doesn't believe in those things right those flags is is the
only association of fascism that is negative the what what would
what would it be even like like the genocides I don't even Oh,
there's like there are ideals that went towards communism that
can be understood and respected. There aren't a lot of ideals
for fascism that are understood and respected with given like,
you know, liberal democracy. There's no overlap, right? It's
got almost no overlap at all. So, it's it's really a stupid thing
to point out like what are you what are the positive ideals for
fascism? There really there really isn't a lot if you believe
in liberal democracy. Um, >> they are sonetized. They're
whitewashed in in America.
>> Yeah. In the deep south, it's normal to see Dixie flags
on people's porches or car bumpers. Sure. Which some people would,
you know, black people might take that as an explicit endorsement
of slavery, but it's uh it's part of the culture. Okay. You can
put whatever flag up you want.
>> I also want to make it clear. I just I make it clear.
I'm not calling it that he should be banned or anything or he
shouldn't be able or allowed to do this. Like I would disagree
with you, Anna, probably that I think they should be allowed
to just like I think you should be allowed if >> I never
said they should be banned.
>> If a Conno boy wasn't a vector to attack Pesco, he would
be defending it. Wait, who's Wait, are people about a Connoy
doing this? That's clearly just a joke. That's like, by the way,
that's the most I say this sometimes. I think I said this during
the Woo thing. And I might have even said I feel like I'm saying
this a lot. It's the most personality I've ever seen from a Kado
boy. That's like the thing that gets him all the time is he's
like not funny. He doesn't do jokes. He's just like kind of dry
all the time. Bro was an E for most of his It's just a funny
Yeah, it's just a funny meme, dude. >> Nothing is bent.
>> And to be clear, he he almost certainly hates those
regimes.
>> You should be allowed to like as a if you wanted, right?
If you wanted to do the whole dress up
I >> if you explicitly disavowed
and people kept calling you an and you could explain they have
no understanding. you have complete understanding of these political
ideologies and they keep calling you an you go oh well I guess
I'll show up to my next stream dressed as an now I would say
there's probably a a limit to how far you could go but the if
the idea is this is a ideology this is a ideology that I totally
disavow
right that I I don't believe in I don't believe in any of the
things they stood for like once you get to full-blown USSR I
don't think there's a lot of overlap with uh with econo beliefs
and the USSR right the USSR is not really the the the actual
realization of communism. It's the it's sort of a bastardized
version of communism or socialism that came about because of
human corruption is probably what a con boy would say. I'm >> I
have a different perspective. I I in Ukraine it's pro prohibited
and and I'm for that but uh uh in the United States I I acknowledge
that you have a different you know vision of like free speech
or what >> oh so Anna is not like
>> just tipped $3.
Okay. Okay. I propose ya that the joke making six pest to make
another documentary
in Minecraft
>> Okay. All right. Thank thank you for the
And I'm not going to impose my, you know, idea about that on
you. That's for you to decide. >> Hold on. I want I want
to point this out though. So we we have um comedy related to
North Korea, right? We have uh Team America World Police. We
have the uh the interview, you know, where where we like satarize
the authoritarianism of North Korea. But realistically, like
at least from my perspective,
it's one of the darkest chapters in American history that that's
still going on where in the 1950s the uh you know, basically
North invades the South. They almost get pushed back to the Pusan
perimeter. This is like a totally forgotten chapter of history,
but you should Google it. Then America bombs the out of the North
Koreans and uh does a land uh a sea invasion uh via a port called
Inchan. We push them back up to China and then the Chinese invade
with two million soldiers and push Americans back to the 38th
parallel. That's the history of the Korean War. And actually
the United States 25% of the North Korean population through
aerial bombard. >> I have to make eggs for my brother.
>> Okay. I actually think that we're pretty up for killing
25% of the North Korean population. But what's happened since
then since we bombed the out of them? I
again is this not just Connor story time? Why the do I care?
Why the does this have to do with having a flag? Are you kidding
me? And China uh basically gives them enough support to survive
but not enough support to thrive. You have tens of millions of
people who are effectively held in authoritarian dictatorial
slavery. Yep. >> And so when he puts the flag up like Yeah.
Like we can laugh, we can joke. Like I'm going to laugh at the
interview. I'm going to >> He is saterizing it in the same
way. He is literally saterizing it in the same way, dude. >> Laugh
at Team America World Police. But I basically see the flag of
like authoritarian dictatorship with tens of millions of people
held in slavery right >> To to be clear, we also have um
media that
satirizes
Germany. Uh uh springtime for Germany, >> the producers,
right? They have all these other things where they they satize
it and I again not to not >> which is what econom boy is
doing. A con boy is mocking you and pretending that like his
beliefs are equivalent to this because he's making fun of you.
He is satarizing both those countries and you at the same time.
>> Delve why does he have where that flag like did he got
hit specifically to put it there? >> There it looks like
he ironed it too. Can I point out that detail? It looks like
he ironed the flags, which is scary to me. >> I thought
that was great. >> He ordered them off of Amazon and they
were still in their eight, you know, fold whatever thing. I would
be like, "Oh, okay." You know, it's a joke. >> I don't
spend an extra 20 minutes per >> Okay. I don't know, dude.
I don't know if you could tell that through the stream for one
thing. I don't Why are you like making Why are you making things
up? Why are you Why are you narrativeizing this further?
Also, I have a steam I have a steamer. Okay. Steamer would would
solve that [__] real >> Ironing that. >> No,
I'll have to go look again. But were those real flags or were
those just photo like photoshopped in? >> No, look. I don't
know. Listen, listen. The fact that that that's fine. And the
fact that Yeah. You know, I'm just not to be dramatic, but uh
right now people in my country before they get shot in the head
are forced to listen Soviet anthem. I just want to point that
out that uh that's Yeah. So I I know. >> And you know what?
I think Aado Boy explicitly thought Ukrainian soldiers are forced
to sing the Soviet anthem. And I know that for a fact and I'm
gonna put that flag up because those Ukrainian soldiers have
to sing the Soviet anthem before they get their brains blown
out. Okay, that's why I'm putting that flag up. Let's go. You
can totally moralize this. You can find almost anybody who's
offended by almost anything on the internet, right? That's not
the space these people inhabit and they continue to associate
with people who do not follow that standard at all. So, it's
shocking that they're now sitting here and trying to adopt that
standard.
>> Seeing that is not fun. It's it's a flag of a of a regime
of the ideology that millions of people here right now where
I am, right? And it continues today to be prevalent in in the
minds of Russia and people like that >> because it fuels
Russian nationalism, right? So e so so even if they um even if
the Soviet Union is collapsed and the Russian uh current Russian
state as far as I know is not pursuing socialism as we understand
it um they still they they look back at the Soviet Union with
roasted glasses and they valorize the Soviet Union as this great
anti-imperialist
stand
>> stop
against the American empire >> against the west yeah and
also the time when they were really powerful which is true you
know and also the time where they were successful as an empire.
>> Just just real quick as well, like people who are going
hard at a Connor boy like like how dare he do that in front of
Anna. He's on his own stream. He didn't come on.
Like I would I would absolutely be with you if he came on this
stream knowing Anna, knowing what she's gone through and did
that. >> I would have listen I would have been totally
fine if Anna just walked away and was like that's that makes
me feel right. But trying to make like a point, trying to actually
tweet and make a point is just
shouldn't shouldn't make public statements about stuff unless
you're willing to like analyze it, right? I don't know. I don't
know.
>> That's a different thing. But he's not on our stream.
We just looked at it. >> Yes. Yes. Yes. But but just just
to point out that uh people would have incredibly negative rightfully
so if you have like a swastika somewhere, you know, on your persona
just for even for memes. Yeah. But they are not when you have
hummer and tickles. I saw the [__] protests in United
States against Trump which I was at first happy about and then
I saw [__] hammers and tickles there and I was no
longer happy about it. Okay. So it's just Yeah, it's just Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. It's just >> the the moral
there there is a different moral calculation though here that
I'm just going to acknowledge is that >> Thank you, Connor.
Is that there really isn't a piece of fascism, not fascism, not
nefascism, neither one that really is like morally good by Western
democ democratic standards. But there are many facets of socialism
and communism that we've adopted, that we've integrated that
seem pretty solid, right? That's got to be what he says. uh American
left-wingers do not view uh they they don't have the same level
of like moral revulsion uh to to socialism that I do. >> But
that's the problem, right? So because uh Bernie Sanders as an
example um AOC is probably too young to have done this. But uh
Nom Nom Chsky for sure like while he's like, "Oh, I'm an I'm
an incrementalist. You know, I don't believe in authoritarianism.
might criticize authoritarianism in all its forms. They'll say
that [__] They'll say that it'll simp for the Soviet
Union uh you know of the 60s through the 80s. They'll simp for
the Mauist China of the 60s through the 80s. They'll make apologia
for Pot who wiped out 25% of his own population. >> Yeah.
Who did Cambodia apology fulltime? Yeah. Chsky and
>> Serbia. Why wouldn't I presume if you're a libertarian
socialist, if you're a syndicicalist, if you're a uh incrementalist,
why wouldn't I presume that one, you could just be hiding your
power level, or two, you're a useful idiot for people who are
more nefarious than you? Are you >> like often times like,
>> so the whole hiding your power level thing, I thought
we all agreed that you look like a [__] when you
call out a dog whistle like it is the thing, right? I thought
we all agreed with like, you know, the okay symbol and all of
this, Pepes, all of this. You look like a soy when you call out
the dog whistle as if you hear it normally, right? You say, "Hey,
why are you using that?" You say, "Hey," you ask a question,
right? That's the response to a dog whistle. Everybody now is
going, "Actually, the response to a dog whistle is to soy the
[__] out and look like a
2020 like 2020 woke gold." That's the That's what you do now,
apparently. Right. This is why you shouldn't hang out with Brianna
Woo. you start to adopt Briana Woo's reactions to things. Connor
is becoming a woke scold. >> Sorry, sorry. Last point.
Often times the authoritarian socialists, the first thing they
would do when they get into power is they would kill the people
that they think wouldn't go along with the authoritarianism.
Half the time they wiped out the anarchists. >> Are you
uh are you both familiar with uh Mike from PA? Do you know who
he is? Do you know? >> Of course. He's a Hassan [__]
S who used to do debates but now he's in his hot box and he just
makes 100 grand a year being a waiting room for >> last
week on my show I think Friday
>> the cowboy hopped in to talk to me and and Talibots
for a little bit right um and I'm going to play a clip for you
guys and I want you to guys to tell me your thoughts here because
this this is my worry with econ boy like this is my basic sure
>> issue and I'll I'll uh pull this up real >> I
need to click on watch it right so we could all see it, etc.
>> What What is happening? >> I see it. >> Oh,
I was just going to give a silly hypothetical. Allah Hassan verse
Trump, um, President of the United States, Mike from PA, or Talibots.
>> I mean, >> so the answer here is in the current
political environment where there's no other people on the left
who are displaying authoritarian like traits, who aren't looking
to denigrate all of the institutions and stuff, I absolutely
go Mike from PA moving further left. Right. Well, although it's
Tallybots, maybe if it was like Trump or something, I'd say Mike
from PA. I don't know. Tallybot, it's like versus I don't know
that that's I don't know that Mike from PA versus Tallybots is
like actually tangible or consequential in any way. I think they
do about the same amount. I don't even I don't even know. I honestly
don't know if there's a lot of difference between them. I think
they'd be basically ineffective. I don't think they have super
strong Well, h how would I put it? Yeah. No, I don't I don't
think there'd be a huge difference. The only difference would
be Israel, right? That'd be the only difference. And then it
comes down to what do you think's happening in Israel? What do
you think Mike would do? I I know people are like after Mike's
comment on the demonic ethnicity. Maybe you got to factor that
in and say, "Okay, the the policy on Israel would be too disastrous."
Maybe.
I think I don't know. I I hope somebody sent him some like literature
that he could go over and realize like that he sounded You would
hope. You would hope >> in the Living Learn episode >> if
if Mike doesn't come out and say like, "Oh, I misspoke here."
if he has no statement on it, if he just wants to hold that statement
in and I'd probably go tally, unfortunately. But I feel like
Mike has got to go and say like, "No, no, no. This is what I
tried to say. I I up. I shouldn't have said this." Right. >> We
really didn't get to learn a whole lot about your actual political
ideology other than >> I'm sorry. This is just uh >> No,
but wait, do you disagree? Like didn't really >> I I'm
wondering if you're making a joke here. Is Is Is this serious?
>> He's not He's not making a joke. >> Oh, wait.
What's funny? Wait, no. Like obviously when I mean she said she
voted for Trump and she said like she had the she used to have
these she said like more what she wasn't than what she was. I
feel like um but uh >> oh he already has to think about
this is part of the problem but yo the fact that you have to
think about whether or not
>> is worse than
I understand Mike like is not a ethnic
chose Pisco chose me over Hassan and I think Hassan's worse than
Mike from PA and it was a pretty easy decision for Pisco he made
the same little quip about but You know, you voted for Trump,
so I have to think about your judgment. But >> Mike's Twitch
name is Central Committee. What do you mean he's Hassan's worst?
Isn't Mike like very much clearly more of like a like the more
aggressive kind of socialist or communist? Like an actual ML.
I think Mike's like way way more that than Hassan is. >> But
he was very easy to >> judgemental. But but basically it
again. >> Oh, that's exactly what I mean. You see, how
do you remove that? >> Yeah. Like this this isn't this
isn't just a the to explain why people people in chat may be
wrong guy. Now I know who that is. The one that was like punching
the couch. >> Yes. Okay. The couch. >> I know that
guy. >> He is an avowed
socialist communist guy who is an authorit. He's a he is wanting
the authoritarian kind of Hassan style things. We know what he
wants. Helen sloth. I explained where this came from. Like I've
heard this talking point before. It's wrong. If you're if you're
educated on it, you should apologize for saying it right.
>> Now, Tally, look, I wouldn't vote for her either if
there were like a Democratic candidate. >> We just tipped
$3.
Like I was saying, why I hear Malaysian Airlines
is doing a discount in case the six pest
Lao Cow wants to make that Minecraft film as a joke. Obviously,
>> I can't tell.
But you're I literally can't tell if that's serious. If that's
like the same TTS or sorry, I can't tell if that's the same TTS.
Doesn't appear to be. Seems like it's my first choice, but she
is far and away so much less
>> than Mike from PA is. And >> that's why I don't
trust them. >> Well, yeah, that's that's what makes me
skeptical of their ability to assess threats. Does that make
sense? Like
>> totally totally makes sense. >> May politically
rant for a moment. So, so the the thing is like with Israel,
you can be a critic of the state of Israel and I actually have
no problems. You could even >> I guess probably from the
same line as Hassan. I think Mike's a little more sincere in
some of his socialist beliefs and seems like it'd be kind of
scary that he would pull back the American military in the same
way we talked about with Hassan. So, I'd probably go tally bots,
I guess. But >> even advocate for a one-state solution,
and I wouldn't give it like a secular one-state Palestinian majority
solution. And I wouldn't give a sh I'd think you're stupid, but
I I I wouldn't care. What what bothers me though is you say,
"Oh, okay. Well, based off of current oppression, when I see
cutting people's heads off with garden implements, that's not
that big of a deal." And you know, settler babies, you know,
like uh settlers who were in the West Bank, you don't get just
to the mill. >> Did Mike or Hassan say that? That that's
like totally a W when somebody's heads get head gets cut off
with like garden
>> Oh, wait. That's a Filipino person, isn't it? That's
like a Filipino worker who got their head taken off with like
a a like a hoe or something. >> Military aged men who have
weapons. You can also shoot the women and children and the babies
as well. That's what freaks me the out because this whole >> Did
Mike or Hassan say you can just shoot the babies as well? Are
we reading that all into the settler baby thing? Maybe we're
just reading it all into the settler baby thing. >> Like
moral analysis is how atrocities are committed. This is how you
walk in as a Soviet soldier and you see the SAR in his family
and you don't just the SAR and his wife, you also the kids. And
so this is kind of like the the >> Wait, can we not does
not Everybody understands why you the kids in a royal su succession
scenario, right? That's not that's so so different a thing. It's
to compare it. I'm sorry. Those are royalty, right? Those are
royalty people with claims to a throne that would have allegiances.
people would have deeply held allegiances to the existing royalty.
I mean, don't sh kid. It's obviously bad to kid, but like it's
totally different in a monarchy, right? In something like the
whatever the Russian monarchy was there with Sar Nicholas at
the end, >> moral setup that you need in order to >> but
like it's just a totally different thing that you're talking
about, right? Obviously, I don't want a kid shot in any case,
but I'm I'm telling you that there's a reason there that is political
that is like beyond just you wanting to like wreak havoc or cause
as much pain as possible >> to commit atrocity and it just
goes uncalled out. Um Hassan [__] too ju just quick
detail um he does 10 toes
>> Would you a baby to prevent Hassan [__]
from having absolute authoritarian dictatorship over the United
States? Quick question for anybody who just criticized me. Would
you? Yeah. Then shut the up. Thank you. >> He supports
the Red Sea crisis. He supports the Houthies firing missiles
into random commercial vessels. There have Philippine sailors
who have been killed. The vast majority of the ships that have
been damaged or destroyed have nothing to do with the United
States and nothing to do with Israel. So effectively he's saying
that as long as you cloak yourself in in the in this exterior
cloth of justice in ending oppression, you can do whatever the
you want. And that's like the communist idea
>> That's an idea. Yeah. That's how they justified red
terror. Uh they uh had the uh in my city by the way >> the
proletarian masses. >> Yes. Yes. They thought they were
doing the great thing in my city. They had like skinned people
alive. They shot them. They put them on meat hooks during red
terror period. 3,000 people just in this city where I live in
particular. So >> I'm sorry I'm getting I'm getting >> even
in the modern context they're denazifying
Ukraine, right? You're you're a Nazi and you're a Nazi apologist
and grandpa fought Nazis so I can fight Nazis. So if I torture
them to death, that's not a problem because I'm >> Wait,
does Connor realize he's explaining why you shouldn't put beliefs
on people that they don't have? Is Connor literally explaining
why the thing they're doing here is for us? Thank you, Connor.
You You love to see it. Connor just actually ran through why
you shouldn't make up what a Connor boy's beliefs are and present
him as somebody who believes these things at all. He's literally
satizing them. And
>> Yeah. I just I I'm sorry. I shouldn't be getting one
guy from chat, but people in chat like, "But Tali is a Tallyy's
a Trump supporter. She's not nearly as bad as Mike from PA."
You guys just don't I think you're just ignorant as to what Mike
from PA would do if he had the power of the presidency. If he
had the full might and backing of the United States government,
>> um, as bad as it is now, imagine that 10 times worse
at the least. He would act
in a jail time. I would just be backed by the power of the state.
>> Yeah, I'd be in a gulag right now if if he if he had
the ability. >> He would >> if he had like universal
dictatorship. Sure. But that's not what anybody's talking about.
That's not what any of these hypotheticals are about. Poor engagement.
Bad engagement from W. >> Okay. because you would be a
capitalist sympathizer. You would be a counterrevolutionary.
And and this is one of the things that I realized too that that's
actually kind of insane once you it's something that I'm still
thinking about. >> So once you conceptualize the fact that
there are two major classes in society, the owners and the workers,
and that we will not know peace until the owning class is abolished
through state power, right? And ultimately we should try to dissolve
the power of the state. But we need to eliminate this because
this is one of the the worst evils that's ever been visited upon
mankind is the division of classes in the majority of humanity
be being enslaved into the working class. That's one of the worst
things. Once you accept that into your brain, then it just kind
of becomes like everything is class conflict. Does Connor Does
Connor think that econom boy thinks that? He's like a PhD economist.
Why would he spend all that time figuring out how economies work
and then be like this is all dumb. This is all working. Am I
I'm not saying that wrong. Right. He's a PhD economist. I think
so. Anyway, keep going. >> And so, as a result, you being
a liberal and a capitalist, it's not a difference of opinion.
You are a slave who endorses slave masters. You are a part of
the evil. You are a part of the propaganda machine that is holding
humanity back. And so, as a result, if you don't apologize for
holding humanity back, you either need to be imprisoned or trader.
That's what it was called. And that's >> class trader.
You're a trader. >> Yeah. So, >> other working people.
>> Yeah. So, just a little uh a little like I guess dive
into the history, which nobody does because nobody knows it,
I guess. But, uh, one of the >> Grinko Kesh, you haven't
demonstrated this at all. As long as you don't think it's the
biggest evil ever, that class warfare is like the class separation
is the worst thing ever. As long as you don't believe that, there's
no reason you have to proceed fast enough that you cause violence.
It's been explained to you by multiple people. I understand you
don't understand it, but that's okay. You don't have to. It can
just be true >> Most like insidious things about uh communism
as an ideology was the fact that the enemy label was intentionally
so broad that you could literally like make any >> You
think you can abolish private private property without violence?
Seriously? Yes. If you get rid of industries, like 0.5% of industries
over a 10-year period for like what would that be? 200 years.
Yeah. Or sorry, no, 2,000 years. Yes. It is theoretically possible
to abolish all capital ownership without violence. It's just
the time scale. The time scale forces violence. >> Anyone
into a class traitor. It was actually the enemy of the proletariat
and also all just the class traitor. So for example with the
it's a little bit more difficult because you can't really make
any everyone into like it's because >> everybody is a Jew
to a lesser extent except the Aryan race. The whole point of
that kind of fascism is raising yourself as a superior race.
So everybody else is inferior especially bad. But like they killed
a lot of gypsies too. They would have killed a lot more people.
It probably would have killed a lot of Slavs a lot more than
they actually did. >> Right. that that would be the the
the you know your ticket to be in a in a camp, right? So you
can't they did actually by the way not label people who weren't
you know to get rid of them who were opposing and like that's
true but it's not >> she saw a chat message that was telling
her that was dumb. >> You I think you all understand that
you can't tell that millions of people are than gays. It's not
really practical in that sense. Whereas in >> she doesn't
understand it. Okay. >> The communist label was the class
traitor, right? the enemy of the proletaria and you can be a
priest, you can be a doctor. For example, um you said uh every
Connor brought that up. Everything needs to be class struggle.
That's even applied to science. Okay. They prohibited
geology. They prohibited
um sociology. They prohibited anything that was in a they was
a hilarious thing about genetics being prohibited because genes
was said to be a bourgeoa concept because uh yeah >> it's
like total thought terminating engagement right now. Right. They're
just giving any possible reason they can to not think about the
things a boy says. I don't want to listen to you a boy. You're
basically you're basically like the right now. You're basically
like you basically have fights behind you boy. I don't want to
listen to anything you say. You say you don't want violence.
I don't care. That's what That's what a Marxist would say. That's
what an ML would say. That's what a communist would say. They
don't want >> Yeah. Well, do you know why, Connor? I'm
>> Well, I was What did he do? A Connor boy showed up for
his show with this background and like a like a I guess this
what would this be? Um like a re a Cuban revolutionary. Is that
what he's dressed up as? >> Yeah. So, basically Russia
in the war. >> Yeah. All her money she makes being online
an online personality she dates to Ukraine. She's an activist.
That's fine. I'm just telling you she's she's engaging in a space
where I understand that she's an activist but now she's saying
so I'm just going to call it that's fair she's going to say we
just all call it obviously probably guess because I'm you know
sometimes I like to joke about racism it's just the fact that
like even the concept that there are differences between human
beings suggests a level of supremacy and so if you can analyze
genetics then you're implying a level of supremacy and therefore
it's anti-egalitarian therefore it's bgeoa >> in a in a
very simple way Yes, but it also was like the fact that in Soviet
Union um when uh the prohibition of uh genetics as scientists
were um made and ge geology as well was because they they there
was it was in the contrast of the Marxist dialect dialectical
materialism, right? It was um they said that the basically the
to explain it in a simple way in English is quite difficult for
me because I know those in Russian you know the the terms but
it is basically what it was is that the um you everything is
nurture.
So you can create nothing is nature right. So you can create
uh you can create you can engineer
society you can engineer
>> yeah obviously all stupid >> um that yeah you
cannot be like naturally predisposed to things you cannot be
um there there needs to be eliminated that idea that this that
there is and that's why basically they >> yeah because
nature could be an excuse for all sorts of anti-proletarian
anti-revolutionary
behavior like like even even for me like Uh, I feel like people
are temperamentally attracted to different things. Well, we we
can't have that because that would, you know, maybe some people
were born to be owners or maybe some people were born to be managers.
Maybe some people were born to be mothers. But that's obviously
>> Re just real quick, $20 from Alexander Ren. Thank you
for the $20 to say, "Imagine tyrants people to preserve their
power and labeling those people as traitors." Then $5 from Audacity
to say
is what I mean. Yeah, you're right. That was what I was talking
about. >> I literally had two or three people in my chat
say the same thing.
>> People over there. >> I cut this off. >> Leah
Leno. >> Lencoism. Anyone else hungry?
>> Leah Leneno is what I mean. Yeah, you're right. That
was what I was talking >> I literally had two or three
people in my chat say the same thing. >> Okay, people over
there. I I want to bring this up though because everybody thinks
that this is like an early 20th century thing where like after
you know around World War II after World War II immediately there
was this authoritarian socialist thing and then the Soviet Union
got better over time and then it collapsed in the 80s and then
we normalized relations with Mauist China and then now you know
everything's fine, right? But it's not it's not it's not okay.
There was the cultural revolution in the 1970s which the United
States largely ignored because we wanted to normalize relations
with China economically. But effectively what happened was Mount
Seong knew that he was dying and he knew that there were people
who were upset with the command economy and that they might want
to revert. Uh guys, we are five subs away from another hour on
the stream. Okay, so consider this a shill. Sub on kick, give
subs, donate to TTS, okay? Anything. patreon.com/jdlk
as well. join the join the community. Join the community >> back
to a free market economy. So he propagandized the younger generation
and it was called the cultural revolution. You can take a look
at it. He basically got them into a fever pitch to preserve communism.
They in the my Chinese teacher um said that capitalist rotors,
people who were paving the road back to capitalism. And so what
happened is they estimate that around 500,000
people were killed, meaning that they were beaten by mobs or
they were just executed, but millions more were accused of being
class traders and they were held in struggle sessions. So imagine
that like you're an American sympathetic Chinese person in 1972.
Well, if you said American sympathetic things in your class,
well, what would happen during the Cultural Revolution is 30
of your own students would show up, drag you out of class, if
you were unlucky, they would beat you to death or you. And if
you were lucky, you would stand there with a sign in front of
you saying that you were a class trader and you would be verbally
bered for hours until eventually the mob let you go. And and
basically like that co that struggle session or whatever like
>> that's relevant to a con boy because he's mocking you
guys for suggesting that he believes in that. >> Apparently
apparently that's relevant to a con boy >> came with the
implication that if you did not accept your sin then you could
ultimately be killed. So you just got to think about that like
this isn't
this was in the 1970s. My parents were 20 years old. This is
not that long ago. I was born in the late 80s. So like this is
recent history. >> Yeah. It's not re it's not also like
the one thing that I really also wanted to bring to your guys's
attention that sometimes you have like
>> Allison, thank you very much for the five gifted. Let's
go. That's another hour in the stream. Thank you. Thank >> These
guys who don't want to like be associated with Stalin, for example,
because that's absolute dog [__] I guess. But they
they they also be like, "Oh, I'm a Leninist." Which by the way,
same guy, just less worse. Like literally same ideology, but
Stalin was just way more um was nicer about it. >> Yeah.
Yeah. Was just nicer about it. Yeah. But that's one thing. And
second thing is, oh, they be like, "Oh, I'm actually not. I'm
not even a Leninist. I'm That makes my spine cringe every time
I hear that. I'm Trokite."
>> Did econo boy say any of those things? Did he say any
of those things? >> Yeah. Yeah. The steel man the other
side
is a steel man. Right. >> All we're talking about is little
streamers. Okay. Right. We're talking about like straight raid.
Um what what she get like 50 viewers something like
>> Sure. But in our space I mean look
>> uh straight raid will replace denims within the next
year if uh if things maintain their current trajectory. I'm telling
you. >> Not like as a Hassan person >> as in a what
would you call it? like a leftist sympathetic straight raid's
much better at arguing her points than basically everybody who
actually does it now. Like she is far better at it. I'm just
telling you there's I'm just telling you. Okay. >> Even
Acon Boy and Pisco Go hate on Hassan, right? They weren't Hassan
simps. They were saying that guy, right? So like >> Yeah,
but they channel people towards them. Do that. >> No, they
don't. They absolutely don't. That is completely >> That's
the problem. Yes, of course. You make you make socialism more
patable and then people like I'm going to check out that Hassan
guy what he has to say and
>> you watch a 10our stream where he doesn't talk about
communism
>> you watch on see about how people attack him for no
reason for 10 hours it's like wait where's the comma I thought
there was like socialism here where is it where it go to it though
th this is the job this is where for instance I was kind of a
gasast and and again I'm not trying to throw or Stephen under
the bus. But I was kind of a gas when we were talking about economics
and he was like, "Well, it's it's it's always sucked." And and
if you're a part of the working class, then your your dad had
it just as hard as you did, and you just need to suck it the
up and shut the up. And it's like, that is obviously not going
to work with anybody. That's not going to work. That wouldn't
work with me, by the way. And I'm doing relatively well. Aaron
kind of though, lol. At least in the economy stuff. Loki Coco,
name me one policy Aaron supported that is economically that
she's come out and said this is the policy I support because
I'm guessing you've never heard her talk about economic policy
she supports ever. And if you have and you can come out and name
it, then you get out of your 3-day timeout that's coming your
way. Go ahead. You got like 5 >> Like I want the economics
to improve. Um >> I want a very very strong community culture
of saying things that you have any idea of how to back up. Okay.
I do not want a community culture of sewing the saying. Okay.
So, you go ahead. You give me the the exact specific position,
the exact specific policy she supported or been against. That
was a totally position cuz I'm Dude, I don't know about you.
I've been working since I was 17 years old. I'm still in debt
and I'm just paying bills. That's all I'm doing. I'm paying bills.
I'm taking care of my family. So, if I >> Isn't there a
self-proclaimed communist? >> Yeah. Said she's the economy.
Do you do you believe anemone that you can be a communist and
still actually go ahead and say I support this economic policy?
Sure. Loki Coco, explain anything that backs up your position.
Give me anything that backs up your position at all beyond just
call me bad. Beyond just call me bad. Cuz as far as I know, she's
very much like, "Oh, well, you know what? I'm a communist, but
also I'm able to read. So here's some economic policies I'd support
that are relevant or could become relevant in my actual country."
feel like I've been given an incredible amount of privilege.
Then I I feel for the working class. >> Yes, I understand.
You just said she's not a scary commie. I'm saying go ahead and
tell me what made you think that she's working on the economy
besides the fact that she said she's a communist. You've got
what, a minute and a half now? Uh 2 minutes 13 two hours 13 minutes
is when we'll check. who works at 7-Eleven for 10 bucks an hour,
60 hours a week, and he has a baby mama that he has to take care
of, and they live on the side of town in state subsidized housing.
I feel for that because I know how hard that life is. Yeah. So,
so if we allow Americans to continue to be radicalized by poor
economics and a bad culture,
I think that the >> Why would you think I am advocating
for copying China?
>> I don't even want like I don't even want to read the
message. I'm just like, what? What made you think that I was
doing this? I'm so confused right now. >> The Hassans and
the Fuentes of the world are just going to be more powerful over
the next decade. We We can't ignore it.
>> What is the >> That's kind of the trajectory.
>> The Hassans and Fuentes of the world. Han is basically
Nick Fuentes, guys. They've actually managed to convince some
people of this. Hassan is basically Nick Fuentes to these people.
I'm just glad that they're normalizing Fentes. It's so nice of
them to normalize Fentos. I don't I won't get made fun of as
much for for watching this guy thinking he's funny. That's an
awesome plan to just normalize Nick Fentes for people. Let's
go. Let's go then. What is the solution here? So, we have these
people, right? We have >> Oh, you Oh, we don't see replies
on the on the >> type, the type ones, right, that you were
talking about the remind everyone that like the people who think
that we can get to kind of a >> people who call themselves
socialists, but they're not really socialists, right? They just
want more government to do more stuff. Then he had the people.
>> Oh, 2 minutes.
2 hours 13 minutes 30 seconds has gone by. Do we have the answer
from Loki Coco on like what he thought was particular of Aaron
to say? Do we have an answer? We don't have an answer. Unlucky.
>> Who are unlucky? >> I one at a time. I think we
just call those people stupid and we try to inform them that
socialism is actually quite >> Okay. Just say, "Hey, you're
calling yourself the wrong thing. We need to deal with something.
>> You're Scandinavian or a social >> True. Then
you have the second Oh, go ahead. It was a warning. >> You
got to stigmatize warning to what it should be as a disastrous,
horrendous evil is what it is. Okay? It's immoral. It's deeply
up. Okay? So, you need to point that out. It's you cannot sanitize
the Hummer and sickles. You need you need to stop doing that.
And you need to be broad, loud, and proud, okay, about how [__]
awful that [__] is and need to need to call out.
I'd say probably it's to normalize or to support like the hammer
and sickle like straight up communism stuff. I I just look at
you like a if you have like a hammer and sickle up in your room,
right? I don't I don't think it has to be stopped. I think it's
like you you seem just really like you could have some ideology
that makes some sense to me, but you seem like a [__]
for like supporting a regime that did so many hor horrific things.
That's probably where I'd come from with it. >> People
like Pisco kind of boy as well >> kind of like kind of
like this like I just kind of think you're a [__]
If you're a streamer, you put this up in your background, you
know, >> doing the sanitizer work, which I appreciate that
obviously, but you cannot be like, h, you know, those guys are
not as bad, I guess, as like fascists and so we shouldn't be
like they're that hard on the rest. No, they're vipers. Okay,
they're vipers and they want to use you, all of you, to get to
their end and to radicalize more people. And they are getting
radicalized. More people think Hassan is based basically daily.
And that's and that's yeah, it's a problem. Um, it's a >> Well,
and and Wick, if you were going to go to the next people, uh,
my solution would be for >> Uhoh. What? Hold on.
No, that didn't happen,
bro. Tell your people to chill, dude. Tell your people to chill.
I do not want to be You don't want me as somebody who's like
uh associated with you guys, okay? You're not going to like that.
It's not going to go well for you guys. Tell your people to chill.
I'm not associated. the li >> totally disavow that account
totally disavow the does
uh I don't want to be associated with doxers you know my problem
with destiny is my issue with bad bat empanada the gat fumodor
guy all these people >> so who actually believe in the
decommodification of basic human need and workers zoning the
means of production but they want to do it in a nice way >> yeah
they want a democracy way right >> yeah I would I would
just take history and bully the out of them with it and then
when it comes to tankies I think we should treat tankeies the
same way we
>> 100%. Yeah, that's that's the same as my answer is the
same. Uh I will say though that um the sanitization is crazy
to me. Like as an Eastern European, I actually spoke with Lonerbox
about that which uh uh it's not I'm not throwing Loner Box under
the bus at all. I super respect him and you know we are friendly
and uh but he told me that one of the things that actually made
him remove socialist label from himself was he had a beef basically
with a lot of people before that. So he didn't agree with like
you know never was a Stalinist like or Leninist simp or anything
like that but he the Russian Ukraine situation like the the invasion
how much how all leftists started sweeping for for Russia and
for doing Soviet apologia
this >> can say that doesn't >> did that happen by
and large I feel like Hassan wasn't doing Soviet apologia he
was doing I don't think Hassan does a lot of he does some like
he has a hammer and sickle up in his place or whatever right
but I thought that like essentially that was just the America
bad CIA doing disinfo.
I thought that was what bit him there. Not like a broad support
of Russia. It was it was literally like oh the CIA is lying to
you. The CIA is trying to manufacture war here and then Russia
invaded. He's like oh Russia is bad actually make
the comparison between Putin and like that he was trying to come
back from I he said some really I don't believe it's like Russian
Russia apologia. I believe he is like a he's a total apologist
for China. I do not believe he's an apologist for Russia in the
same way to be honest >> sense because the modern Russian
state isn't even the Soviet Union. So it's like this it's like
this romanticization of of Russia. It barely makes sense. >> It
does if you recognize that a lot of these people it does it isn't
about Russia is are you an enemy of the United States? Then we
like America. >> That's it. Yeah. Yeah. America bad. That's
America bad. And also their actual the Schroinger moment I talked
about they they say Soviet. >> Okay. What did Wick did
>> in Russia? It barely makes sense. >> It does.
If you recognize that a lot of these people it does it isn't
about Russia. Are you an enemy of the United States? Then we
like America. That's it. >> Yeah. Yeah. America. >> It's
like people
people get soy they like forget the the narratives they've already
committed to. >> Uh that's America bad. And also their
actual the Schroinger moment I talked about. They they say Soviet
Union wasn't real socialism,
but we have nostalgia and sympathy towards it. So that's kind
of funny. But that's one thing. And also the other thing Loner
Box told me is that he went on a trip to somewhere in the Baltics.
I think Lithuania or Estonia he said, I don't remember, but somewhere
in the Baltics. And he was there when he was still like associating
himself with the socialist level. and he saw the museum of anti-communism
and anti-fascism on the exact same street and they basically
had yeah they had like a Stalin candle and candle candle that
you can light up and see them melt and that like kind of made
him understand that just it's based it's everywhere here by the
way that but you you can you can really like see it's another
world with the people who actually lived under those things that
the people who suffered the most from communism and at the same
time
There's a there's a limit though that I want to point out. So
So for instance, I think with >> if we talk to Latvians,
Lithuanians, Estonians, Ukrainians,
Polish, East Germans, all that kind of stuff. I think they would
say like, "Oh yeah, the the authoritarianism of Russia was a
nightmare. You know, they did all this crazy them, blah blah
blah blah blah." But I think if you I think if you talk to Russians
though, I think if you actually look at polls, a lot of them
look back at the Soviet Union as like a moment of pride in their
country's history. So they might admit to some of the [__]
that was up about the Soviet Union. Um but I think it's it's
probably close to 50% or 60%. They actually look
>> Oh no. >> back at the 19 >> Connor do not
bring math up right now favorably.
uh because they felt like they had gotten away from all the authoritarian
[__] up. Um but they were still like a unified
power and so so they're nostalgic about >> Yeah. They were
at the top. Russians were at the top of everyone else. Obviously
they will be nostalgic about it. But it's you know >> so
you're saying ignore the Russians, talk to everybody else.
Really like >> All right. Fair enough. >> The nostalgia
is based off supremacy. It's quite simple really. It has all
to do really with communism. It has to do with the fact that
they were the the the the majority power. They were everyone
else was under them and they really feel as you can see now.
>> So you're saying they they don't miss socialism. They
miss being the top dog in Eastern Europe. >> Yes. Yes.
It's incredibly important for them to be in the top dog in Eastern
Europe and it still is really. So and also they were like treated
as a actual real uh main >> uh if audio is desync you should
restart the stream. power really at the time, right? So the antagonism
with the United States being on the geopolitical, you know, Mershimer
like basically being like the the bipolar like
multipolar world order. Bipolar
bipolar world that kind of girl see [__] is what
they really miss. But people who suffered don't miss it. >> Anna,
can you uh real quick, can you DM me your email just because
I have a couple of people in chat who are asking for your PayPal
so they can help support your work. Yeah, of course. Thank you.
>> Yo, you're respectingly grind
Twitter in my YouTube description. So, if you want to find it
there, she posts her her uh gofund
time, right? Her fundraisers for uh the people in Ukraine, the
soldiers in Ukraine who need equipment and things like that.
And you can go find her there. $10 real quick for from Audacity.
>> Don't say the Scandinavian system works mainly because
of national hegemony and social obligation to the system. A lot
of Scandinavians understand how fragile their systems are. You
don't just quote unquote do socialism.
Um, that's another >> Somebody told me that. >> Oh,
go ahead. >> No, can I expand on that real quick? Somebody
said that there's some
>> I hate it. I hate it, but I have to I have to I have
to highlight it. It's unfortunately too funny not to >> Indonesian
cultural thing. I don't know if it's Swedish. I don't know if
it's Danish, but it's effectively like a cultural trope of like
you're not hot, so stop showing off. Which I think is so funny
because like Americans like we, you know, uh, America
I think I forget who it was. It was some French guy, but he said
like America is a country of temporarily embarrassed millionaires.
And I think that's so funny because even if you talk to like
>> Oh my god,
does Connor also know that like Steve Bushi was a volunteer firefighter
for 9/11? Does he have any more Reddit facts to share with us?
Connor, you got more Reddit facts? Connor, I love Reddit facts.
Oh my god, thank you. >> A guy who works at Walmart. Well,
he's an aspiring rapper and you should check out his music on
Soundcloud. If you talk to a guy um you know who who uh he he's
runs a 3D printer store. Well, actually, he's doing all these
3D designs and he's gonna become a millionaire by selling them
on the internet. >> Talk to some guy who just got out of
the military. He's an upand cominging streamer. You should check
out his stream and go check out, >> right? Yeah. Wick or
counterpoints. But, but yeah, like everybody is a temporarily
embarrassed millionaire. Whereas in Scandinavia, they basically
say, "Shut the [__] up. Do your job. You're not that
special. Contribute to society and go home." which I think is
like it's so
contradictory to the American perspective. I don't know if we
could pull off the Scandinavian model because we all want to
be temporarily embarrassed millionaires. >> No, it's just
so the >> No, they want to be millionaires.
>> American dream, I guess, in a sense, but also like you
I I got to know a lot of Americans, right? Uh in recent times,
most of them are based because they're here, you know? So it's
like uh but I talked about them with them like about a lot of
things really and uh one of the things was like just how like
hyped the culture in United States is like individualism is incredibly
strong which is you know it's not bad necessarily I'm just saying
like how it is like in terms of like culture right which in in
Scandinavia you're absolutely correct and we also have that you
never hype yourself up you don't show off and you try to be like
this you know just like everyone else really like that's kind
of like the the culture right and this is a completely different
culture and you know I know all white nationalists in in America
think that if you're white that you have exact same culture but
no American Americans are so different in culture that from from
from us for example I have more in common with my bajani friend
okay and he's a Muslim and you know yeah so it's just I have
literally more in common with him than with any of you I mean
I love you I'm not saying you're like bad or anything I'm just
saying you know >> and you're and you're the you're the
crazy eccentric one you're the bluehaired fairy who's traveling
around the front lines. So, but like as soon as as soon as you
turn the webcam off, you just go back to like >> Why is
the guy tweeting my offic
like Hassan reaching >> Oh, it's the Myron versus I see.
Why are you tweeting my you as funny as it is you? It's the uh
about like Hassan Ra who would genocide like I think Myron would
genocide before would I'm dead serious about that. >> No.
Does he think I would deny that? Well, actually.
>> Oh, yeah. No. So, Oh, wait. I was like, "Oh, he just
has the correct opinion. He just has the exact
correct opinion." And then Oh, wait. Hold on. Hold on.
>> I don't know. Actually, that would actually be a hard
one cuz >> Would it Would it be a hard one? Would it actually
be a hard one? I'm really It's hard to say, actually. I'm not
sure actually. Okay. All right. Yeah. This is probably the most
clip that came out of this entire thing was actually I think
uh I think Assan would fewer more Jews than my gains. I think
Assan's way worse for the
>> Damn that was crazy. Okay.
>> All right. All right. Where are we going back to this
>> putting on like a walking around with like a bag of
potato Eastern Europe? I want to talk about our culture for a
minute because I I think it is the American like other countries
have experiences with socialism like bad ones right they like
oh this is the period of our history where a bunch of people
died right America doesn't have that same history right it doesn't
have that same
>> at least against whites
>> true one of the reasons you're so successful is you
never had that to set you back off for hundred Yeah, if you talk
to if you talk to Native Americans or black folk, then then I
think they'll probably tell you a slightly different story about
American authoritarianism. But but I think that uh white Americans
like pretty much everything before World War II was like a joke,
you know? It's just kind of like a meme. Like whoops, like we
we conquered the entire continent and dispossessed the Native
Americans. But realistically, >> there weren't that many
many of them >> Yeah. I'm not talking about authoritarianism
in general. I'm talking communism specifically. And that's why
we're weak to communism
specifically cuz I don't think we knocked out the Native Americans
because we were commun right like I don't think we did that >> Uh
but like there's this this idea that American exceptionalism
combined with this like oh well those other countries just didn't
do it right. But when America does it when America does communism
we are of course going to succeed cuz we're American right >> we
can do it. Okay. Oh, those other stupid Russians on whatever
the [__] else like
just upset cuz nobody out here out there calling him a gay little
boy. A little gay boy from Chicago. Well, that's true. >> All right,
what are we what are we doing here? That's that got boring. Um
I think we're going to look at apparently Trump. The way this
was pitched to me was Trump basically says that Joe Kent is actually
CIA. Let's see what it looks like. It's my pleasure to nominate
Joe Kent as the director of the National Terrorism National Counterterrorism
Center as a soldier green beret and CIA officer. Okay, never
mind. Never mind.
Oh boy. Oh well, unfortunate.
Un
unfortunate.
Okay, so yes, CIA officer. Okay, I think you're supposed to keep
that one to yourself, bud. Okay. All >> Wait, what do you
mean he?
>> True. Mentally, he declassified it. Everyone can know.
Is he leaking to the whole world? Hard to say. Hard to say. >> A
leak. Declassified through tweets. >> Oh boy. Oh boy.
Let's give this a quick read. Tucker Carlson exposed from contrabat
freedom fighter to exfox news host. Tucker Carlson is a failed
quote unquote CIA agent spending his entire life serving the
deep state. To understand Tucker, you have to grasp his background.
Tucker's father, Richard Clark Carlson, is the CIA's top guy.
did happen to work uh happened to work for the C for a CIA cutout
happened to worked for CIA cutout voice of America starting in
1986 at the height of the cold war. Ronald Reagan himself even
anointed as an associate director of the United States information
agency founded to create pro- US propaganda in countries like
Nicaragua, Cuba and the USSR. The $4 billion a year USIA was
so large while was running it, the top 20 PR firms in the US
combined were outsized.
Serving as director of the USIA was vital in bringing down the
anti-US government in Nicaragua in the late 1980s and early 1990s.
In 1990, Dick Carlson addressed the Knesset 3 years later addressing
the UK's House of Commons. You can see where the Carlson's loyalties
lie.
Carlson's loyalty lies. In 1991, Carlson left Voice of America
after he was nominated ambassador to seal by George Bush. Dude,
that's a sick gig. State Department diplomats comprised the vast
majority of official cover CIA operatives due to diplomatic immunity.
Was heavily involved at Intermedia, a cold war era global research
consulting firm dedicated to collecting data on poor nation citizens
for the US government. Later providing info to Bill Gates and
Harvard to help improve third world birth rates.
That's a funny one. Just given what this guy no doubt thinks
right in 2003 joined the foundation for defense of democracies
FDD during the Iraq war to push neocon chicainery. The FDD in
recent years has had leaks showing it directly coordinated with
Israel in the Israeli lobby. Later join I mean I would need more
information there. That seems like what do they email them like
you guys want to get lunch on Thursday? Later joined the institute
for the study of terrorism and political violence. During that
period in which Dick joined the FDD, its board included former
CIA director R. James Wooy
and Jeam Kirkpatre uh Jiang Kirkpatrick. I don't even know how
you say that. Uh Jean Kirkpatre, a high official at a high official
at the center of Iran of the Iran Contra affair. Now Carlson
works as a lobbyist for the heavily lyudaligned Orban government
in Hungary as a registered foreign agent. Little is mentioned
how Tucker Carlson's origin story begins in the 1980s as he traveled
to Nicaragua in the midst of a bloody civil war as a freedom
fighter for the US backed Contras. This included Tucker going
to rallies for the Contrabacked candidate Vetta
Shamurro.
It was to the point that Tucker, the foreign college student
with a dad leading the CIA's war against the Sandinistas, was
magically literally standing next to her, Shamurro, as she won
despite high level uh security precautions.
Soon after traveling a second time to Nicaragua, Tucker then
applied to join the CIA. He was rejected and his father advised
him to become a journalist because they'll take anybody. After
graduating in 1996, Tucker was wrote deep or Tucker was wrote
deep state puff
Tucker has wrote deep state puff pieces in Bill Crystal's weekly
standard about how the CIA had no involvement in the war on drugs
and the contras were actually removing drug dealers. Before Tucker
Carlson's character change, Carlson openly described himself
in 2008 as a trust fund baby, saying, "I'm extraordinarily loaded
just from money I inherited from a number of trust funds." In
2009, soon after joining Fox News as an analyst, Tucker said,
"I am 100% as whatever Mr. Murdoch says, I do." It's no coincidence
that Tucker married into the multi-millionaire Swanson family,
famous for their frozen food empire. Tucker's interests are aligned
solely with the very upper class ruling elite he denounces on
his show. That's like that's true, man. Some of this other stuff
I I get that it's like saying it. I would love to see a little
more. So, this is just showing that he was a part of these different
firms. His dad >> link the Wikipedia of the sources.
>> Yeah, I don't know what this is either. What is this
text from his position as the head of USIA role in the US dirty
US's dirty hybrid war against Nicaragua can be reasonably surmised,
but far fewer people know that a young Tucker himself also played
a part in it. While still in college, Tucker and his roommate,
friend, and Daily Caller co-founder Neil Patel went to Nicaragua
at least two times to, in Tucker's own words, get involved in
the war and support the side that was right, which was not the
Sandinista side. Interesting.
Interesting. Very interesting. 1990 Carlson join. This is like
a big one for them. He he addressed the Knessetic, guys. He stood
in the chamber. Do we know if he touched the wall in 1990, guys?
So, do we know that yet? All right. What do we got here? I think
that's basically it for the the
Carlson. Oh, no, no, no, no, no. Wait, wasn't there more of this?
Didn't Fentes talk about this again tonight. Am I
>> Wait, is he he started stream tonight? >> No,
he wouldn't have started stream tonight. It wouldn't have been
tonight. I thought I saw another clip. I'm
>> But I don't know if his Yeah, he's streaming right now.
>> Bad thing is, and I know that no one who I mean, this
is part of the >> sideby-side comparison of Tucker Carlson
attacking Pat Buchanan and Nick Fentes. 25 years later, it's
different costume and it's the exact same story. >> The
sad thing about Happy Canada as far as I'm concerned. >> Sad
thing is, and I know that no one who watches him will believe
me. >> That does raise issues that I think um are important.
>> Doesn't mean everything he says is false. It doesn't
mean he's not talented. He's enormously talented. Doesn't mean
he's a bad person. I'm not attacking him personally. >> I
mean, I think that, you know, the sovereignty of the American
military, etc. I mean, these are not just crank issues. It's
young white men who've been totally cut out of our economy, attacked
mercilessly. I mean, they really are the victims and they're
desperate and no one speaks for them. So, they go to Fuentes
because he's like incredibly articulate and they think he's our
leader. >> But unfortunately, Pat Buchanan raises them
in a way that I think is >> But he is clearly part of a
campaign to discredit non crazy. >> He's speaking. >> Yeah.
Sorry. I can't believe Tucker Carlson got away from this. Got
like out of this. How did he ever get away with wearing this
bow tie? How did How did this get like memory hold that he was
the bow tie that got dumpster? Didn't he get dumpstered by John
Dailyaly? John
>> Not the golfer. John Stewart. >> Not the golfer.
The Daily Show is John John Stewart. Okay. Different guy. But
like, yeah, the the bow tie guy. How did he How did he get any
credibility back? >> Right voices. >> Pat Buchanan
is part of the reason it's so hard to have that conversation
because he discredits it by his by his >> That's a campaign
to destroy credible voices on the right. and Fuentes is part
of it >> and that he believes in conspiracies and and that
he believes that that are this sinister secretly organized force
um trying to affect American politics and those aren't discussions
I think normal people u sober people should be having >> anyway
like who is this kid exactly >> and maybe it's just an
accident that the guy goes after exclusively goes after people
who are in the same roughly the same and then he gets up there
and It's like, you know, making Holocaust jokes. >> When
it's hacked, he can always fall back on the line, well, the,
you know, the tiny cabal that controls American politics doesn't
like me because I speak truth to power. This is actually, incidentally,
almost verbatim what he said the other day, that I offend the
putoaucracy.
um that I'm a wanted man by the inside the beltway people and
and in in every sense cast himself as a as a victim who is sort
of a Karen Silkwood of politics, someone who's uh so truthful
that he's being hunted down by the uh by the conspiracy that
runs Washington. I mean, it's all a bit much. >> Well,
I would say K there's a little bit here in that I believe Fuentes
modeled some of his stuff after Pat Buchanan. No, I thought he
said that openly that like he really appreciates Pat Buchanan
as as like a voice. Maybe I'm crazy. So, of course, some of the
criticisms would overlap. That does seem a little little weird
that Tucker's getting lazy about it. 25 years later, a quarter
of a century later, and it's the exact same story. It's literally
the exact same story. Calls for regime change in Iraq, then calls
for regime change in Iran. Now, Pat Buchanan running as a spoiler,
as a third party. >> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. I thought he opposed the
bombing of Iran. I thought Tucker was like mocking Ted Cruz for
being behind like going to war with Iran. No, I don't think you
can put that one on Tucker. >> Republicans then me tell
>> Yeah. Does he want regime regime change? I haven't watched
his interview with the Iranian president, but >> Oh, I
didn't know he did that, but Tucker super did. Really? I thought
he didn't support bombing Iran or I thought he didn't support
bombing Iran like um for Israel right now. >> I could have
sworn he fought with Ted Cruz on this. Maybe he doesn't, but
he still wants the regime to change. I don't know. I don't know.
>> Maybe
didn't support the regime. I don't know. Maybe >> calling
the gropers not to vote for Trump because of the war in Iran
now.
And verbatim the same script back then. Pat Buchanan is spoiling
the conversation, discrediting real voices by his presence. Nick
Fuentes is part of a campaign to discredit authentic America
for his voices. The only thing that changed is the costume. >> You
notice that? The only difference is the costume change. 25 years
ago, he's wearing the bow tie and the navy blazer and khakis.
And today, he's wearing his flannel shirt, signature flannel
shirt on his own network in his log cabin in Maine. That's the
only thing that changed.
25 years ago, he was just playing a different character. 25 years
ago he was playing one of the Brooks Brothers
hanging Chad's
type elite conservatives which were in vogue back then. And now
that we have a populist conservative movement made up of Matt
Walshes and Trump voters and the uh swamp people, the duck hunters,
what do they call them? Now he's got his flannel on with his
sleeves rolled up. And as Candace Owen said, he really just wants
to hunt and fish with his kids in
costume change. 25 years ago, he was a member of the elite. Since
Trump got elected, he underwent a rebrand and became a populist.
I'm fighting for the people. I'm one of you. Look at me. I'm
wearing a flannel and flipflops. I like Zen just like you. I'm
a regular guy. But it's >> it is it is just totally transparent,
isn't it? >> Same attack. And what the attack comes down
to, as I said last week, it's a gatekeeping limited hangout operation.
>> GG, Ogre Boy, you're destroyed, >> Jim. It is
It's >> Oh, also I think I've got all the Hassan stuff
after this. So, if we have more hours on the stream, we can go
to actually watching some of these Hassan clips and we'll we'll
pick apart whatever he's saying. >> Explicitly telling
you these are the bounds of acceptable discourse. It is okay
to talk about the Israel lobby. It is not okay to talk about
Judaism.
These are legitimate issues and I think people should talk about
them, but the way he talks about them is all wrong. It's hateful
and crazy. He says that he's being accused of or he says rather
that he's playing the victim. He's attacked by the inside the
beltway crowd, but that's just a fallback. That's just an excuse.
He is a legitimate anti-semite. Sober people should not be hearing
this. Sober people should not be discussing what he is discussing.
It's the exact same script. And honestly, I saw that clip and
it's it's just disturbing. I don't know what else to say other
than it's just disturbing because it's literally the exact same
script a quarter of a century apart. They've been doing this
for a long time.
>> Quarter of century. Other than it's just disturbing
because it's literally the exact same script a quarter of a century
apart. They've been doing this for a long time. He gets a lot
of mileage out of that phrase. They've been doing this for a
long time.
If Fentes is still a fed. Um, maybe. I thought I thought this
was kind of mostly dispelled at this point. I still think the
way Cozy was founded was weird that like Cozy could have been
a honeypot. I thought there was like some concerns there on my
part. Cozy might be a honeypot, right? But I don't know, man.
I don't know. Who is they? Well, it's not the Jews in this case.
He means he means the CIA actually. Rare instance where when
he's talking about them, he doesn't mean them. Very rare for
Nick
You you'd never expect it. Crazy.
Let's see if we got anything more from the Anna thread here.
Anna being upset makes sense, but this is pretty funny. And surely
the Destiny sub of all places is not going to clutch pearls over
edgy jokes. Yes, thank you. This guy is not I think the point
Anna makes is that if this was a right-winger dressing up as
a calling you would call them out for being a cryptofas.
No, you wouldn't. No, not if the whole point was
if Ben Shapiro showed up if people kept calling Ben Shapiro and
Ben Shapiro decided to show up in like in a outfit, okay, with
a flag behind him, people would not say Ben Shapiro is actually
they wouldn't do it. Sorry.
Yeah, here's the thing. Yeah, exactly.
Man, sorry. This guy says, uh, "Down vote me all you want. If
I was a right-winger and spite driven to, uh, to to trigger people
who irresponsibly call me an I'd 100% do this." Of course, that
is this is provided that I've established that I'm completely
averse to not many times before. It's the basic tactic of ironically
leaning into labels your enemies put on you in order to show
how stupid it is. The only difference is that in this case, said
label is infamous for co-opting irony and dog whistling, which
obviously creates room for valid skepticism.
Uh-huh. There's no way. You just you just basically said that
isn't famous for co-opting irony and dog whistling. My friend
my friend most masterpiece. Have you heard of a person named
Nicholas J. Fuentes? Have you heard of this guy? Have you heard
of this guy and his enjoyment of baking? Huh?
>> Oh, Loki Koko. If you did relative work conditions,
you could argue this in in a vacuum or conditions. Probably not.
Obviously not. I don't know if that's economic illiteracy or
like life experience, a lack of life experience. Not sure which.
Okay, hold on. This guy responds, "Oh, this guy's downvoted though."
Yeah, I don't know. This should be the most upvoted comment by
a lot, right? That like, "Hey, it's just it's just an edgy joke,
bro. Come on." Could be a funny bit and sanitiz sanitization
can also be a problem, but he doesn't believe in it. I honestly
don't understand why everybody talks about edgy jokes. This is
not about edgy jokes. How is this the response? Destiny himself
said he doesn't think that a con boy is a secret tanky. How is
that helpful?
How is that? How is that? Come on, man. Ah, the subreddit's cooked.
The subreddit's cooked. It's cooked.
>> All right. Loki Coco. Gotcha. Gotcha.
Did Anna come out and say, "Obviously, I don't think there's
a problem with economy yet." Nope. Has a boy responded? I want
to see the econo boy response. That's what I want to see. Show
me the account boy response. Come on, man. >> That was
scroll down. That was a crazy tweet. Scroll down more. That that
tweet to
Jesus. >> Feel like Putin is in your country for